Dance Moms wasn't on Nickelodeon yeah
it's also not a Nickelodeon no so I um I
signed in the Nickelodeon when I was 13
or 14
um and it's uh it's a full overall 360.
so for the last like
for the first there is the right words
for the first five years of being signed
with them it was products it was music
movies television brand deals everything
you could imagine
um was they essentially owned and did
with me or did for me and then once I
turned 18 we uh added on a little more
length onto the products so that way I
could do my own thing and have my own
rights for Music Television movies
social media brand deals all that
um so we extended the merchandise
because that is the business with
Nickelodeon that really was explosive
um and got free and clear for music
everything but when you turned 21 it's
gonna be all you yeah so January this
year I believe is when it's flips I can
do anything so will you have to restock
that like what would I see in Target
yeah Walmart and everything they're
going to be all new products out there
yeah so it's it's it's a little it's
there's this interesting Gap that we're
in right now because I
am now an adult you know and I'm gonna
be putting out adult music but the the
boomerang and the kidney candy story
that like the little kids love will
always be there because it's just online
and all of that content that I produced
myself being a kid from age 12 till I
was like 17 when I stopped doing YouTube
and stopped doing kids music that is
when that all that's still there and so
new kids are still just discovering it
Boomerang alone gets about 200 000 views
a day oh wow still to this day I know
it's I mean it's eight years old and so
we're at this weird Crossroads of like
those products will just kind of sunset
out from Nickelodeon will they or do
they keep those products so going I mean
listen I think it's gonna be uh it's a
Crossroads that no one's ever crossed
before because no one's
ever done a deal like this with a
Nickelodeon a Disney a big Warehouse a
big Powerhouse no one's even really
crossed into the social media influencer
having mainstream merchandise
essentially
and so it's kind of the first and I I
always joke around whenever I do new
things I'm like the kids in 10 years are
thanking me for figuring this out for
them you know what I mean it's like
Paving a new way same way that the kids
20 years ago paved Coogan accounts for
me you know what I mean
um for those that don't know the Jackie
Coogan was one of the Our Gang uh kids
and they uh they made it so that the
parents couldn't take all the money so
that the if you're a minor and you're
working you're guaranteed a certain
amount of money 15 of every penny you
make has to go into your Google account
which now they're starting to do for
social media kids as well which is
interesting because that's my gratitude
alarm every day at 12 I say what I'm
grateful for
yeah yeah no it's it's interesting
because I
was I I mean I have an incredible family
around me who would who would never do
anything anything shady but there are
parents and there are kids who are on
YouTube and there's no there's no law
did you get to keep the major percentage
of what you made of course yeah my my
family is so great um yeah we we
it's it's been fun to figure out as I'm
getting into an adult like how how we
want to streamline it a little bit like
the Nickelodeon deal yeah family deal
let me ask you something why wouldn't
you maybe this is just boring because I
just love business why wouldn't you make
a deal with Nickelodeon now because as
you said if you go and you start making
your own products you're not going to be
promoting or representing the products
that already exist yes for Nickelodeon
which are doing well yes so they're
going to lose them anyhow would you ever
approach Nickelodeon and say hey let's
restructure that deal so you don't
Sunset out and it could be a 95.5 on
your part instead of losing it and I can
have 95 of it and I have the power of
Nickelodeon still behind me no if I if
how how exposing of of my life do I want
to get right now if I had
the control over my products that I've
wanted for the last
nine years eight years
it would be a different story
but you couldn't have but you can what
I'm saying is you're calling your own
shots now yes there will be yes you know
when when you're 21. whatever you do
you're going to do yeah do you want the
everything that exists go to go by the
wayside it's very profitable and very
and the kids I'm just watching my
granddaughter the kids love it yeah so
why would you just let it go
I won't be letting it go it'll it'll so
instead of instead of it being
Nickelodeon JoJo siwa it's gonna be siwa
JoJo siwa so we have all of the
relationships with the people who
actually create the merchandise
and so instead of it being me
Nickelodeon people who create the
merchandise store it'll be me people who
create the merchandise store
yeah but I was thinking more like in a
record deal you know if you have a
record deal if you're signed to a label
they keep going with the music that
music goes you go to another label even
if it's your own label and you're you're
doing yeah that music keeps going but
you're doing more of a Taylor Swift kind
of thing in the sense that she
re-recorded oh we record my own and
there there is I mean I don't know the
exact legalities of it there is uh
whatever we have already done keeps
going and we can keep selling and that
could go on for who knows how long but I
will say the company as well
has shifted
and they shifted a lot when I came out
and I I actually I ran into the old
president the other day two days ago and
I was like man I miss you and she was
and I told her I was like you look good
like you look like you're happy and she
was like yeah I've been thriving for a
few years now and um it's interesting
it's it's hard when it's
you and it's not a not a character and
you're being treated and sold like it's
a it's a character you know and I've had
to put my foot down in a pretty
aggressive way being young
on some things that I shouldn't have had
to and um I'm excited I've I've wanted
to
be in charge of it
[Music]